[ __ ] welcome to the best cooking show on
earth my name is David Selwyn I just
smashed my knuckle into this washer and
dryer who the [ __ ] put some washing and
drying to a kitchen anyways what the
[ __ ] are we cooking today we are gonna
be cooking one of my favorite things to
eat on the face of this earth my friends
I can eat a sandwich every day for the
rest of my life and be happy that is how
much I love sandwiches I'm like Joey
from friends I [ __ ] love sandwiches
you can do it whenever you want I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm saying so today
I'm gonna be making my world-famous
probably not because nobody knows about
it it's basically a pork loin sandwich
with delicious provolone cheese homemade
Mayo and some broccoli [ __ ] Rob you
are going to need to have to get a
ziploc bag ziploc sponsor me I need the
money I got these cute little tiny ones
simply because I can I'm not gonna be
able to eat both these whole things but
we're gonna throw it into the ziplock
bag and the cool thing about pork lowing
my friend is that it's high in protein
low in fat and it's relatively
inexpensive you can season it before or
after you put into the bag but if you
want to know how much salt you can put
in it
I'd say the amount of salt you put into
the bag is the amount that you would use
when actually seasoning the piece of
protein like so I like heat I like to
throw in a few chili peppers and once
again this is just whatever you want to
flavor it with this is what I'm going to
be doing so salt pepper chili flakes and
of course we need a little bit of all
the oil or as Rachael Ray calls it evey
oo extra virgin get your rosemary you
don't actually need to strip it off the
little [ __ ] throw it right in there
because it's gonna get happy anyways we
are going to Suvi this [ __ ] so no
worries three
cloves of garlic lime lemons oranges
whatever you like I'm just gonna squeeze
half a lime in there cuz me like the
citrus flavors leave it in the fridge
overnight or if not just sube it right
in to this water bath right here I like
to sue FEMA okay me too I like to sue be
my proteins because it kind of takes the
guessing game out of everything you cook
it in a water bath and its own juices
it's always gonna come out to the right
temperature and it's always going to be
juicy but if you don't have one of these
bad boys sear it off on a pan throw it
in the oven and wait until the
temperature gets to about 140 degrees
and 140 degrees it's gonna be about
medium so slightly pink on the inside
bet you know you could eat pork like
that huh dunk it in the water have oh
[ __ ] maybe I should have done this
before the water was hot cuz that burns
like a [ __ ] and boom there it goes it's
gonna be cooking in this water bath for
about 30 minutes and then we're going to
come back to it and imma show you how to
finish this [ __ ] off to every great
sandwich man Aves
mayonnaise is the moist maker of every
single sandwich and if you are going to
buy mail in the store that's completely
okay but once you make your own you are
going to be completely changed the first
off we are going to need a
room-temperature egg now if your egg
isn't room temperature and you left it
in the fridge just get some damn warm
water and put the [ __ ] egg in there
man simple [ __ ] pop over your food
processor like so pop the egg in BAM
like so so I'm gonna throw a few grounds
of black pepper some people are like why
would you do that you could see it who
the [ __ ] cares it's gonna come out as
poop anyways you get a grainy mustard to
add into this as well why you ask
because the great make sure you shake
your grainy mustard up put it in there I
say oh just a little bit like so it's
good for flavor and also it stabilizes
your damn Mayo you also have the option
of adding something acidic vinegar lemon
I'm going to add a little balsamic to
mine because that's my preference
just a damaged good up and then we're
gonna let it go we're gonna grab
ourselves whatever oil that you prefer
some people like sunflower oil and all
that other [ __ ] peanut oil something
doesn't have a lot of flavor let it go
[Music]
and slowly
Brown mayonnaise I'm gonna throw a
little chipotle chili powder because I
want my [ __ ] to kick time has passed the
sous-vide is done my friends ah let's
check up on our cylindrical piece of
meat so the [ __ ] have sous-vide they
are nice and already cooked all the way
through to a perfect medium now at this
point we can't let this dead piece of
meat go right into the sandwich we can't
actually because it'll taste good on
them but we're not going to let it get a
hot put some oil in the pan
cuz we are going to sear our meat once
the pair gets ripping hot coated all the
way around like it is around here
so before we sear it just remember take
off all that moisture because with that
moisture hits that pen it's going to
boil it and so we need that surface to
be dry throw it in the pan get a fork
tongs whatever it's just gonna sear on
each side for roughly about a minute or
so we just want that Brown crusty
vacation at this point what are we gonna
do you ass move it this way take a good
look at these lovely pieces of garlic
crush them crush them my friends throw
them down on that side remember that
piece of rosemary you had in there
earlier put it in there don't let it go
to waste
get a fat knob of butter like so and we
are going to base the bad boys in butter
and olive oil and garlic take that
delicious piece of meat bring it over
here and let that get happy it's already
cooked all the way
next up the final part of this is the
delicious broccoli rabe do you know what
broccoli rabe is I don't [ __ ] notes
we're gonna take these stems and we're
gonna saute this [ __ ] off in that
delicious brown butter that we had
earlier
we're not gonna waste [ __ ] I'm at least
up in the parking send off you could
actually eat this but I want it to be on
the more tender side so I'm not gonna
use these today not all of it
after your broccoli rabe is done move it
off to the side take it off the heat we
are going now going to slice the pork
loin and let me show you how awesome the
[ __ ] is there we go
then little slices that I'm actually
going to put into the sandwich you could
have thick ones I prefer it then I like
layering it on that way remove some of
the string that was trussed with it take
that take that take that take that and
take that take your favorite piece of
bread just gonna do a little petite
sandwich like so my god this is a
[ __ ] crouton alright next plan we're
gonna take some sourdough coz that [ __ ]
was hard as [ __ ] remember that broccoli
broccoli rabe you had earlier take it
out the pan remove it to a dish or in my
case just right on the other side of the
cutting board like that and you know
those little deliciously fried pieces of
garlic you're still going to take it out
the pan because we're gonna actually put
that in our sandwich we're gonna take
the leftover of this fat heat up this
pan again and we're gonna toast this
bread the new bread that actually tastes
good in the fat so the fantastic thing
about this sandwich is the fact that
calories is the who the [ __ ] cares part
about it I like to use an aged provolone
if you whip this out the bag it smells
like death and feet but that's what
we're looking for nice piece of cheese
right there then you're gonna take that
delicious broccoli rabe place it right
there on top of the provolone next up
that wonderful sliced medium pour
tenderloin place it however you like
like so and then with that we're gonna
add one more piece of aged provolone
take your other piece of bread has been
toasting in the pan right over here and
not to forget that lovely chipotle mayo
that we made is not going to waste we
are going to spread that on this side of
the sandwich you could add mustard to
this if you like I'm actually okay with
mustard I'm gonna leave it on this side
smash it here and remember this pen
we're gonna take him back to this and
we're gonna heat this up until the
cheese melts so after a few minutes and
it got extra toasty on the other side
and it's finishing browning and melting
away take it out the pan like so get
yourself a nice sharp knife I'm just
gonna use this because it's on hand
diagonal I feel like doing it right in
the middle I'm rebellious like that and
right there you will have yourself a
delicious broccoli rabe roasted butter
tenderloin sandwich and
well [ __ ] right there [ __ ] good man
if you want to break up some of the fat
with this don't be afraid to get some
mustard some nice grainy mustard and put
it on there because this right here is
the future wanna have a good time with
it impress your friends take your
parents out to brunch but making this
delicious sandwich I guarantee you
everybody love you the great yeah like
[ __ ] help you're gonna do this to me
you're gonna embarrass me in front of
all the youtubes I am going to what the
[ __ ] were they doing why didn't any of
you say anything as I said before I
don't waste anything as I just throw
this into a garbage can can't actually
use that put a delicious piece of
provolone right on actually you know
what before we do that what the [ __ ] do
you know what that's cool
we're gonna do that let's dig it